[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
m
et
[Musique]
m
d
[Musique]
et
là
tél
nous sommes restés au moment où urbain
et bruno rentrant deschamps ouvrez la
barrière effrayés par les cris de suzy
il se précipite dans la cour
oubliant de refermer
[Musique]
m
bon alors si ces personnes de chez nous
selon l'api dit le fermier très en
colère mais papa merle qui prenait l'air
sur une branche de l'arbre bord dans le
poulailler l'a entendu
et c'est ainsi que négus le corbeau l'a
pris
madame pipi madame pitt
le bracelet de la petite suzy de la
ferme a disparu le fermier vous accuse
et il dit comment accuser mois moi qui
suis innocente je n'ai jamais vu ce
bracelet il m'est arrivé enfin il
pouvait m'arriver le prendre au mot sans
le vouloir des petites choses mais un
bracelet au fait qu'elle est et comment
ce bracelet en or alors un bracelet au
nord je m'étouffe jamais une chose
pareille mais d'arriver au nord
et c'est moi qu'on accuse mois une
innocente au secours au secours
[Musique]
oh
pendant qu'à la ferme toute la famille
du fermier continue ses recherches les
plus fébriles
le vieux coq lui cours de toute la
vitesse de ses pattes
il atteint la forêt
ouf
jamais de ma vie je n'ai couru
pareillement tiens je ne savais même pas
que j'en étais capable
makan ihome à cannes
ils font qu'y tour a beau ne ferme il
salue quelle triste sort hambach dur que
ce te parle que d'un but de si beaux si
beau
mais changer un bon âge quelle triste
sort que triste sort des tenures un coq
au vin pour tous les jeunes locaux
quelle triste sort triste ça
[Musique]
il faisait jour encore la route est
belle et comme il est agréable d'être
libre et de cheminée sans contrainte
[Musique]
alors y'a pas à dire la liberté lax
au secours cet animal qui m'a frôlé
annonce n'est rien c'est une feuille
morte
wow quelle peur je n'ai pas l'habitude
d'être seul et sur une route déserte et
certainement plein de dangers
mais la liberté ça s'apprend
j'apprendrai allons mon vieux jo soit
brave ton père était un grand et beau
coq il était brave ton grand père était
un très très beau coq il était brave ton
arrière grand père mais au fait comment
était-il l'arrière grand papa nous en
sommes il devait être très très braves
alors soit digne d'une aussi grande
lignée et en avant et hardiment
redressant la crête geôles coque sans
fond sable
[Musique]